but no I never went to like real acting
classes so we had to like go to the
acting class and it was weird me being
there like I'm writing a thing about
being an actor so I just want to observe
and the actors are like you're on
television dummy
you know oh my yeah but I'm not too good
you know actually I don't have a drunk
story but I have a getting stoned story
the first time I got stung all this
donors are like Sara Goldberg who was in
that scene she's great in the show but
she said she wouldn't know if I was
reacting in character or if I was
reacting as the director right cuz she
would say we'd be doing a scene and I'd
be going DeNiro yeah it's great we're
him and toned look where he's Yellin
like you could tell Tomac and that scene
is like what is happening right now well
he goes ah you get shot walking your
doggy
thank you good - looks like I do what
yeah well you would do a show and in the
middle of the show you know like my
friend from Oklahoma or whatever would
be texting me like that was stupid
[Laughter]
you're like oh I didn't like Stefon this
week okay great you know whatever it is
you're checking your texts during the
show we all do really do you miss the
live shows at all no no no I got very
nervous I had a lot of bad anxiety
Lauren Michaels try to help me after
season four he went you know you can
work here as long as you want and that
was his way of like chill out and I go
yeah you know I'm friends with Judd
Apatow and Seth Rogen and they went to
your house and would yes
yes yes I they did come to my house
and I and I said a Seth Rogen was like
you know it was amazing he has like you
know a bike track in his backyard
it was phenomenal and I did a Seth Rogen
impression and it was like I did a magic
trick Tom Cruise is like yeah Bill Hader
good morning hi how are you HOT leading
man I mean it's just like a dream come
true or what I never imagined that no
yeah no no I didn't know now one of the
movies I worked on was collateral damage
Arnold Schwarzenegger and and one of the
scenes of the scene where I'm it's
really intense scene where there's a
bomb and a room and Arnold has to get
into the room and eat it and eat the
bomb I needed and his line was open up
the door there's a bomb in there
[Laughter]
and so they go hey bill we need you to
operate he's like one of the star Trak
doors you know like and so he's like
bill you need to operate the door for
this I was like okay so I'm I'm like
right above them like with a pulley
device you know like looking down at
Arnold like this and he's like push-ups
he's like oh come on come on you know
and I'm like oh no this isn't good you
know so they're like all right and
action open up there's a bombing dude
come on and he starts being in this door
and I'm like hold on I think they gave
me my cue they're like door a door a
door and I pull the thing way too hard
anyone with Henry Winkler and a
fantastic actress named Sara Goldberg
and it's a scene from the show Barry
yeah and he is your drama your drama
teacher right your drama yes and it's a
show it's called Barry in this show
have you ever been attacked by an animal
no but I used to live in this place in
LA that had the like the you know the
washer and dryer in the back that was in
like this little shed oh and it didn't
have a light it just had a little bucket
with a flashlight in it and I would go
out there late at night to do my laundry
and then I would turn the flashlight on
and you would hear like a and then I
look over and then right over by the
dryer you just see a possum tail just
don't just knows I make a soft touch
when it comes to I laugh very easily so
I guess you cry as well very easily no
I'm dead inside you have a very strong
supporting cast on the show including
Henry Winkler Henry we you know for me
Henry Winkler was like my he was on my
lunchbox going to school every day
you're younger than I am so you probably
didn't have that wait wait I'm by that I
mean I've heard you saying it's fun to
go to different parts of the country
because of the way people say Harry yeah
in Austin it was like so man you're with
the show Barrett I was like excuse me
yeah and then in here I come to New York
and it's like so Bill Hader with the
show Barry
[Laughter]